-Welcome to the show!
-Thank you.
I'm so thrilled to be here.
-You have a fascinating story.
You were born in India.
You became the first
Indian-American woman
elected to Congress.
You moved here alone,
I believe, by yourself
when you were 16 years old.
-I did. I did.
-And went to Georgetown.
What was it like being here
for the first time at that age?
-It was a strange experience.
I was so young.
I had never seen snow before.
I hated wearing socks 'cause
I had never had to do that.
-Yeah. I feel the same way
about socks.
[ Laughter ]
-I still don't like to do that.
I had a picture of the Taj Mahal
on my wall, and --
-In your dorm?
-In my dorm.
Yeah, I just went out
because I was homesick
and I bought a picture
of the Taj Mahal.
It said "India" on the bottom.
And then my next door neighbor
came in and said,
"Oh, my God,
is that your home?"
[ Laughter ]
And I thought she was kidding,
so I said,
"No, it's the servants'
quarters.
The home doesn't fit on the --"
[ Laughter ]
And she said, "Oh, my God,
are you a princess?"
I said, "Yes, but I'm
embarrassed to be called
Princess Pramila."
She bought the whole thing.
A week later somebody came up
and said,
"Are you the real-life
princess?"
[ Laughter ]
-Wow, how did they
get into Georgetown?
[ Laughter ]
-So you obviously,
as a co-chair of
the Progressive Caucus,
you've been very critical
of the President.
Have you ever met the President?
-I really have tried not to.
-Yeah.
-[ Laughs ]
-That's probably a good...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...good idea.
You endorsed Bernie in 2016.
-I did.
-Which makes sense as someone
who's the co-chair
of the Progressive Caucus.
You've not endorsed anybody yet.
What is it that you're
looking for,
and are you going to endorse,
or are you going to just
sort of wait it out and see
what happens?
-No, I'm probably going to
endorse, but not too soon,
because we have 98 members
in the Progressive Caucus.
And it's a really important
thing, I think, for me
to just stay back
a little bit,
but I am looking
for somebody who is bold,
who is unafraid to take on
the special interests,
who understands that
the inequality we have today
started long before Trump
and that we have to have
bold solutions
for some of the worst things
that we're facing --
climate crisis, inequality.
Three people in the country,
two of whom live in my state,
have the same wealth
as the bottom
160 million people.
So I just think we need somebody
who is willing to propose
solutions that match the scale
of the crisis.
-You --
Medicare for all...
[ Applause ]
...has been a question
in a lot of the debates.
They've been sort of asking
candidates,
"Put your hand up if you are
pro- the idea
of only having
public health care,
no private insurance companies."
-Right.
-You've introduced
a Medicare for all bill.
What is it -- How do you feel
like you move this forward?
Do you believe it's what
the public wants,
and do you feel like politicians
are hearing that?
-It is absolutely
what the public wants.
70% of Americans want a single
payer health care system.
And no, politicians are a little
bit behind the eight-ball.
They're not quite there yet
because they've got to take on
the insurance companies
and the drug companies
that are profiting
off of people's illness.
That is just wrong.
Everyone should have
health care.
It should be a human right.
You shouldn't have to pay
copays, premiums,
and deductibles.
And when you get sick,
you should go to the doctor.
And we don't need all these
private insurance companies,
and they are charging
enormous amounts of money
and stopping people
from getting health care.
-You -- Another issue
that's coming up,
obviously in the debates
and people are talking about it
these days is immigration.
What is the value right now
of having someone like yourself
and colleagues of yours that
are in Congress right now
that are immigrants?
Is it -- Does it add value
in this conversation?
-Yeah, absolutely.
I mean, there's 14 of us
out of 535 that are
actually immigrants
born outside
of the United States,
and it is a personal experience.
For me it took me 19 years
to get my citizenship,
and know what
the system is like.
I've worked on
immigrant rights
as an activist for 15 years
before coming here.
And I really understand
how immigrants are often
the scapegoats, and that's
true for a long time,
but it's certainly true
with this President.
And so to be able to be there
and fight back
and show the resilience
and the courage and the benefits
of immigrants across the country
as a member of Congress,
but also to be able to talk
about the policy,
has been amazing.
-You have -- You've only been
in Congress since 2016.
Is that right?
-Right.
-And yet there's this
freshman class right now
that you're sort of one of
the senior members of.
But I guess you can sort of
show them the ropes --
you know, AOC, Ilhan Omar.
-Right.
-And Rashida Tlaib.
-Are you a close-knit group,
as it seems?
-Yeah, they're amazing.
And, you know, there are
only 67 women of color
that have ever served
in Congress out of 11,000.
And so we're a very
tight-knit group.
I mean, we really --
We like to make soup
with each other.
We like to have wine
We like to just tweet
each other out
and hold each other up.
We go to each other's
press conferences.
It's really wonderful.
They are smart.
-Man, soup and wine.
[ Laughter ]
D.C. is as exactly as exciting
as I thought it was.
Hey, thank you
for making the time.
It was wonderful talking to you.
-Thank you.